as the pandemic has spread all around  the world this past year museums and  other organizations realized  they needed to preserve this moment in  history they started collecting  artifacts  like ppe and vaccine vials doctors  nurses and other frontline workers also  put together an  audio library and they tell the stories  of what it means to be a healthcare  worker in times of crisis  they also discuss grief and sacrifice  what did you learn from listening to  some of these audio diaries one thing  that i realized is the importance of  leadership  the importance of touch and connection  not just with our loved ones at home but  in the hospital yeah i think we've  realized a lot the past year more than  700 recordings will soon be on display  this will be at the u.s library of  congress to help younger generations  understand the importance of history  we've certainly lived through a historic  year